- So the question is, can
Congress impeach president Trump
after he's already left office?
It's a really interesting question,
because the text of the Impeachment Clause
of the Constitution seems to imply that
the person still holds an office.
After all one of the main
results of an impeachment
can be, although it's not
necessarily, removal from office.
Remember the impeachment is the indictment
and then the Senate would try
the actual impeachment charges
and potentially remove you from office.
Then again, another one of the punishments
is not being able to hold office again.
So that might be a reason
to try them afterwards,
but in terms of historical
precedent in 1876
the Congress actually did impeach
the Secretary of War who
had already resigned.
So there is some past precedent.
Anyway, stay tuned for
more election coverage
and I'll see you in court.